quelle douche fraîche manigat pas dre
une prière matinale pour les voyageurs
adelante est une bénédiction pour le
trajet qu'il s'apprête entreprend un
long chemin fricheteau au rituel
immuable à la paroisse notre dame de
guadalupe
depuis un mois le père rice lives et
accueil des demandeurs d'asile de
passage leur offre de quoi manger et un
coin pour dormir
surnommé le curé car boys ce prêtre de
la ville de mes jeunes au texas est une
petite célébrité dans la région connue
pour son combat contre le mur à la
frontière et pour son dévouement en
faveur des migrants
ils font ce qu'ils peuvent pour survivre
dit il alors on doit faire ce que l'on
peut pour les aider
l'école étant fermées à cause de la
pandémie le prêtre a décidé de faire bon
usage de ces locaux vacants en ouvrant
la porte aux migrants nous l'avons
toujours fait mais à bien plus petite
échelle dit il se voit dépassé dans la
situation où 150 à 200 personnes
défilent ici chaque jour envoyée par les
centres d'accueil des environs ou touche
déborder des femmes et des enfants
surtout comme maria luisa gomes partie
il y à huit jours du guatemala
elle s'apprête à reprendre la route car
elle vient de recevoir l'autorisation
d'aller rejoindre son frère au
mississippi les migrants qui sont ici
sont les chanceux ceux qui ont pu
prouver aux autorités qu'ils ont de la
famille ici aux etats unis un endroit où
rester pendant l'étude de leur dossier
c'est d'ailleurs le grand changement par
rapport aux années trump la promesse de
joe biden de traiter plus humainement et
nouveaux arrivants mais tous n'ont pas
cette chance
rinne festina lopes dit avoir un frère à
philadelphie mais elle ne peut partir
car hélas perdu ses papiers
alors elle doit prendre son mal en
patience en attendant que tout soit
régularisé
elle s'apprête donc à passer une
huitième nuit dans l'école avec sa fille
evry toutes ses possessions réunis dans
ce seul sac d'épicerie les autres
reprennent la route à destination des
quatre coins des états unis
rêvant déjà d'une nouvelle vie
le père ait nights leur offre ses
bénédictions
mais s'inquiètent en constatant la
montée de l'intolérance dans son pays
c'est un poison pour la communauté dit
il lorsque les gens commencent à s'en
prendre aux pauvres et aux démunis
aide et son prochain selon lui fait
partie du devoir chrétiens jésus joseph
et marie rappelle-t-il ont tous été des
réfugiés ici jean françois bélanger
radio canada mais sean au texas